- This is a geoduck.
It looks like a penis,
but its a shellfish.
It is the largest burrowing
clam in the world,
and it also is one of the
longest living animals
of any type.
It is native to the northwest
coast of North America,
and since we're in Seattle for a weekend,
we had to try it.
(upbeat music)
- [Gerry] So, I'm blaching
the geoduck in hot water
and then going chuck it
real quick in some ice water
to stop the cooking real quick.
The only cooking that we did
was just so we could peel
off the outer skin.
(upbeat music)
We have the siphon, the
belly, and the inner organs.
You're going to eat the
siphon and the belly.
We serve it sashimi style,
just thin, raw slices
of both the belly and the siphon.
Little bit of geoduck.
Little bit of salt.
Our lemon zest, followed by our shiso oil.
Our red pepper curls
and our radish sprouts.
- Alright, lets see.
I read online that it tastes like cucumber
and it kind of really does.
In comparison with clams and oysters,
I like this consistency better
because it's not like mucus.
I think this would be really good
if it was breaded and deep fried,
kind of like calamari.
Now that would be my shit,
cause calamari kind of
has the same consistency.
That film would make it for me.
- I'm afraid of most seafood,
but I'm gonna face my fears today.
Whoa.
The coldness took me by surprise.
It's very cold.
It's just like really tender sushi,
almost melts in your mouth.
It's fishy, but it's not overwhelming.
This is pretty good food.
It tastes a lot less weird than it looks.
Alright, Quileny, you're up.
- Let's try something new.
Not going to lie, the
body of the shellflish
is sort of imposing and kind of looks like
the downstairs part of a man,
if ya know what I'm saying.
But in these thin little slices,
it's a very sexy fish.
Ugh, I had a really hard time,
cause I don't want to make it seem gross,
cause it tastes really good,
but the way that it felt in my mouth.
If you're someone who
eats based on texture,
it might not be what you're into.
- It's pretty tasty.
- It is.
I feel like, yeah, the
tastewise was really good,
just texture for me wasn't the bag,
but I totally agree.
If you're going to come here,
you should try everything at least once
to figure out if it's for you.
(upbeat music)